what makes predictive modeling difficult
we have millions of patients we want to
analyze their diagnosis information
medication information and so on all
this data combined together
create a big challenge the second
challenge in predictive modeling
is there's so many models to be built
predictive modeling is not a single
algorithm it's a sequence of
computational tasks
we've introduced predictive modeling
pipeline in more details in the previous
lecture
the truth is every step in this pipeline
has many different options
all of those combined give us many
pipelines to be evaluated and compared
you might be wondering why do we need
different algorithms for one problem
are five different algorithms really
necessary
can we just decide which algorithm works
best and use that for every problem
we did look at when you should and
shouldn't use each of these algorithms
whether there is limited data
performance thresholds or compute power
limitations
this isn't one size fits all there's no
free lunch theorem works for every
problem
we know some of the tendencies and
strengths of each algorithm
we can use that to narrow down the
algorithms that we're considering for a
given problem
but what are the questions that we need
to be asking
when do we not to use certain algorithms
generally these questions fall under two
broad categories
accuracy and latency we'll start with
latency
we talked about how logistic regression
is really fast to train
while svm are quite slow so
if you have limited compute power or
limited time then you'll want to lean
toward logistic regression
the next question is how long maybe
if you have a lot of real-time data
coming in that you need to make really
fast
real-time predictions on then you might
want to consider logistic regression
now moving over to accuracy what does
our data look
like is it short and fat
is it long and skinny for instance if
it's short and fat
in other words it has a lot of features
but very few rows
we talked about how svm does quite well
in this space
the next question is just how complex is
this data set
are there clear connections that should
be easy to pick up on
if so then we should start thinking
about prioritizing time to train or
predict
however if the relationships are really
complex then we'll probably start
thinking about something like
multi-layer perceptrons or svm
where they take a little longer to train
but they're much better at picking up on
these really complex relationships
lastly how messy is our data if there
are a lot of outliers
then svm is probably a good choice while
logistic regression probably is not
using the tendencies and strengths of
the algorithms we can narrow
down the algorithms considered for a
given problem
but the bottom line is sometimes we just
don't know which algorithm will perform
best
so we just need to test a few and see
which actually does perform best on the
data that we have
generally you'll start with maybe six or
seven algorithms to consider
you'll narrow it down to three or four
with these questions and then you'll
just test those three or four with
various hyper parameter settings to try
to find the best model for the data and
problem that you have in front of you
we've learned about some of the
strengths and weaknesses of each
let's compare these five algorithms
across six key dimensions
before we run an actual comparison of
each model the six dimensions that will
compare across these algorithms are
problem type
time to train time to make predictions
interpretability
performance and performance with limited
data
this table will help you to decide when
to use each of these algorithms
for problem type logistic regression and
svm can only be used in classification
in other words they can only be used for
problems with a categorical target
variable
multi-layer perceptron random forest and
boosted trees can be used for both
classification and regression
in other words they can be used for both
categorical and continuous target
variables
training speed this is particularly
important
if you have a lot of data or you have
compute restrictions
in those cases training speed can be
prohibited
random forest is relatively fast
and the other three are really quite
slow with svm
probably being the slowest this also
will depend on the hyper parameter
settings for each algorithm
for prediction speed boosted trees and
logistic regression is considered quite
fast
again recall that boosted trees are
trained in a parallel manner
so it's quite fast the other three
algorithms although quite fast
but is behind logistic regression and
boosted trees
for interpretability the reality is that
none of these models are particularly
interpretable
logistic regression is probably the most
interpretable by offering some tools to
understand what's going on under the
hood
of the other four algorithms boosted
trees in random forest
is slightly better than multi-layer
perceptron in svm
because at least they offer that how
different features are contributing to
your model
performance is a big one for obvious
reasons
boosted trees is slow to train and it's
not interpretable
but it's highly flexible and typically
performs very well on almost any problem
multi-layer perceptron also perform well
on most problems
but it's a step behind boosted trees
random forest and svm
are then a step behind those two and
logistic regression comes in last on
performance
again this is subject to things like the
size of the data
the shape of the data and how messy your
data is
now in the big data era it may seem odd
to have a column here for performance on
limited data
but you might surprise that a lot of the
industries deal with small set of data
but with a lot of features
svm is the one that really excels here
especially when you have a lot of
features but not a lot of examples
logistic regression also does quite well
with limited data
the one that is severely disadvantaged
is multi-layer perceptron now that we've
compared all these algorithms
let's compare them all based on
performance on the validation set in the
next lecture
you